not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah's book like
you've never had before
[Music]
foreign
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing shoulder so um
today is wednesday wednesday is a day
usually we
meet with zeeshan me him and hijab go
over some stuff chill play a bit of call
of duty
before that we go to the gym now with
ishan you know um but i told him um
usually with these days we like to chill
because you know we do a lot of work
toward our table studying so we're just
like we need a day to just detox
mentally detox um but i came across a
video somebody sent me so this video was
of the sister who's here um
sister
it's a pleasure what's your name
my name is karen but you can call me
norah now nora so that's your muslim
name now yeah nora yes mashallah very
nice name sister so yeah i was telling
zushan at the gym and i was like bro
you know um i came across like this
video of the sister um she's a revert to
islam
um and she has watched you know mohammed
hijab and other people's videos
and
i was really touched by it because i
could relate to it when i watched that
video i saw you crying multiple times
and it really really touched me and i
was like man like i really felt for you
um in a way where yes i know some people
be like okay you know you feel sorry for
her to me it was a bit of
feeling sorry for the sake of allah but
also seeing
it's not like having foresight like
having like you know but it's i knew
that allah had good plans for you and i
don't i meant this in a way where
something what i've experienced myself
so we know like for example when the
prophet peace be upon him went to the
heavens um you know um and he this is
where he was told about the five um
salahs of islam
basically the five days
uh first it was 50 and then the process
of salam was on his way back down and he
came across musa and when he came across
musa
him he said look
i know i have experience with my people
they're not going to pray
50 times a day it's not going to happen
yeah so i said go and ask your lord for
mercy meaning to drop it down so
obviously the process of telling when
and allah dropped it to 5 but the reward
is still 50. if you do it you know it
depends with hosho and all this kind of
stuff the reason i mentioned musalam in
the process of sallam is the person
obviously had knowledge but muslim had
also hikma as well wisdom because he's
had first-hand experience so when it
comes to what i said about yourself
is
and i always say this to reverts yeah
and i had to get this off my chest to
you and i asked you i said look we can
do this off camera or on camera it's
totally up to you yeah
but i had to tell you this was going to
be set to you off camera on camera you
know um because i really felt that you
may have wanted to hear this
i believe allah just as he sends
messengers to different nations yeah the
allah says we do not we will never
punish our nation until we send the
messenger yeah i believe every revert be
it like you be like me be like many
other people you are we are ambassadors
to islam yeah allah chooses you to
convey that message to your family now
when you convert this message to your
family just like the messengers they got
rejected
they were insulted they were sometimes
assaulted they had to leave their houses
sometimes they returned back to those
houses like the person said i'm
returning back to mecca with mercy after
they persecuted him for him and his
companions and killed some and tortured
the lord for 23 years
they came back and the family accepted
islam and the house that now
the you know the progeny is muslim so
what i wanted to tell you sister nora is
before we say i want to hear everyone
wants to hear your story
um is that
do not lose hope yeah um and
have no doubt allows a plan and before i
get into details this is about you not
me a lot of people say brother ali you
talk too much let your guest speak
sister nora tell us a bit about yourself
tell us a little bit about your journey
okay so
my journey really started last year in
the beginning of last year when i got
out of high school i wanted to get
closer to god
but um the only way i knew how to get
closer to god is to
read the bible go to church more often
do all that because my family was
christian
my family is on and off
with christianity we really only go when
something happens in the family when we
like when we get reminded of god you
know
so um
i took it upon myself to buy a bible an
english bible since my family is
hispanic
um
um the the holy bible in spanish is
really formal and it's really hard for
me to understand
so i got an english bible and so i
started studying i started taking notes
i downloaded the bible app
[Music]
i joined elevation church which is which
is like an organization
from north carolina
and they would broadcast
their sessions online
so i would watch like two or three times
a week you know church
and so um
yeah and that started that and so
everything was going fine you know um
and i've always always prayed and i
always asked
god to guide me to always
[Music]
to make me a better person to um
to lead me to the right path right so in
this video um popped up
it was christianity and islam at the
time i didn't know anything about islam
i didn't know what a muslim was
the area i live in i can count on my
fingers how many muslims i've seen
muslim women
um that i've seen
it's not too much i don't know any
anything
where where i live there's
probably like nine churches around me
just where i live
so it's a very christian community
so when i um
yeah so that's all i knew so i was just
trying to get back into you know finding
god and
doing what's right
so
this video popped up it's about
christianity versus islam i think it was
the muhammad hijab and david wood
okay debate
yeah
yeah so i i kept delaying that video for
weeks but it just kept on popping up
whenever i watch church online wow it
just kept on popping up yeah
so
i was like
let me just watch this video and even
though it's two hours long
let me just concentrate and watch this
video
um
i wasn't really taking sides because i
was still learning about christianity
and i didn't know what islam was so i
was just kind of in the middle of i was
trying to you know humble myself you
know and listen to
i think it was muhammad hijab so um
yeah and i watched the video and then
after that it was like
my whole mindset changed i'm like
islam
one god
christianity
trinity
so three
but islam seems so much simpler than
christianity
why is that
so then i started
watching more of muhammad hijab videos
and then your videos and i and then i
just kept learning about islam for about
seven to eight months wow so um
yeah eventually i i kept watching videos
about christianity and islam compared
and then eventually i just started
watching videos just about islam
so once i learned
more about islam
and that
i really didn't
believe in christianity anymore
it was just something
that i just grew up with no one really
taught me that much
okay even though my family has two
pastors they own a church but my my part
of the family they
we weren't really devoted like i said so
he wasn't
he wasn't that pr okay would you say
that he was at a point of your life
where you was not
was you ever a practicing christian
no i don't think so okay so did you have
a moment in your life where you was like
okay i want to be a practicing christian
yes
so then
is that when you made the prayer to god
or does it did that happen after so did
you say okay god guide me i want to be a
practicing christian or did you want to
be a practicing christian and then ask
god for guidance
i
yeah i wanted to be a practicing
christian and then ask god for guidance
i think that's how it was okay yes so um
yeah i um
it just came a point i think it was
december 28th it was that night where
it was time for me to go to bed and i
wanted to pray
but i no longer wanted to pray
you know the christian way
so out yeah so i just got up and went to
bed
and then
for four hours i just cried because i
just didn't know how to pray i just
didn't know how to what to believe in i
didn't know
how to please god
i was very almost confused but i knew i
wanted to be muslim
okay so you know when it comes to um
the trinity what confused you because
what was it that you thought okay look
christianity is not for me because when
i first looked into religion like i
didn't believe any religion i was a bit
agnostic
i believed in a higher power um what
made you like think you know okay
christianity is not for me like
personally for me
was two issues number one
that
if god almighty exists
this whole concept of trinity
um hinduism
any religion any religion that was had
this you know polytheism you know um
polytheism you know in in in in the
banner of monotheism but it's really
polytheism over manifest we believe in
one but you know there's two or three or
there's one million but the main god is
all these kind of things i was like that
doesn't make sense to me and
someone might say okay well just because
it doesn't make sense it doesn't mean
it's not real but that we know there's a
nature of god yeah and the nature of god
is that he has to be one he can't be
more than when allah says in the quran
if there was more than one they would
fight each other they would want power
you know and if there is two who created
her did a great b or did b create a you
know so the thing is there's a lot of
you know logical um
illogical uh things about it so for you
what was it where you said okay islam is
for you like at one moment where you
said okay hold on a second actually
so i i looked at the trinity and it said
you know the holy spirit is god jesus
god the holy spirit is jesus
you know all that and it was three
it just didn't make sense because there
are verses in the bible
where jesus is praying
but to who is he praying is he praying
to himself if he's god yeah exactly in
the mountain of gethsemane in the bible
he said jesus went up to the
mount uh hale mountain and he prayed
um so the question who they pray to even
uh when he was being crucified he said
he said you know my lord my lord you
know why it was forsaking me um for
example
in another verse in the bible it says
uh he says hero israel our lord god is
one
um when in another verse where someone
came to him and said you know oh good
master what must i do to get eternal
life he said why do you call me good
there's only one good and that's god
alone and you see this throughout the
bible where jesus always refers to the
father he always refers to the father
you know all praise and we do that you
know the one who always prays is god if
someone comes oh you are a wonderful man
i'm not god is
the trinity
was the
problem for you yeah
yeah the trinity like for example a lot
of people a lot of christians the
trinity doesn't what's one of the
reasons they leave christianity it just
doesn't make sense you know who you're
supposed to pray to the holy spirit the
father jesus and then some say no you
pray to the father in jesus name
but anyways yes
okay so
you turn to allah and allah says in the
quran
allah says that
we respond to the quran of the quran
that calls upon him like yeah
so this can be anyone and that's what
you did and it's very interesting allah
works in miraculous ways you know um and
subhanallah so now
coming to the main issue
what happened after so
you know you want to be a muslim it's
very interesting because you're in
florida
i'm in south carolina the closest
mosquito is like half an hour 40 minutes
away mm-hmm
can you yeah to me that is profound to
me that you know when allah subhanahu wa
the spanish foreign wants to guide
someone and you ask for guidance you're
in the middle of nowhere
and
this video just pops up and via this
video
you are just you know guided to me that
is amazing you know um so you said that
he was at a point in a video where i
watched he was kind of you know upset
crying and you said that you don't have
any muslims to turn to you applied for
some work a job can you tell tell that
story
yes so um
when i when i took my shahada
i started praying i started i didn't
have a job so i had all this time
so there was no excuse for me to not
pray my five prayers yeah so i started
praying and every prayer i asked allah
to give me a job because at this point i
i've been jobless for about three four
months yeah
so i asked a lot um
to please give me a job to please let me
um help out my mom
because she was really struggling with
the bills
so um
i really needed you know help
with a job so i applied for
two retail stores they're the same
retail stores but in different locations
yeah and i get the call for for the
first retail store
and then for an interview so i go there
um
what i noticed first that the manager
doesn't look me an eye very dismissive
um
he says yeah you should get this
position
and then he tells me that hourly pay and
which is not really good it's not what i
can do and he tells me that it's only
part time yeah when i told him i was
looking for full time yeah
so he he almost kept pushing me to get
this job
um
and so i eventually just got
mad i just didn't
want to be there anymore he was very
disrespectful
yeah
so i just got up and left
okay so i got up and left um
i felt like
um to be honest i felt like really
betrayed that allah wouldn't you know
allow me to have
a job you know because i've been
applying and interviewing for a while
now
so for this one to not work after i took
my shahada i prayed my five prayers and
then gone through that with my whole
family i just felt like what else could
go wrong you know
yeah so either it happens you know with
me as well there's a lot of difficulty
i've been through you know and allah
says you know do you think we're gonna
say we believe or not be tested yeah um
and the thing is allah will push you to
your limits it's a test
uh but at the very end where you know
this sometimes you despair it's normal
human beings and with you it just
you got your prayers answered how did
what happened
yeah so um not even a day later i get a
call
it's this lady and she says um
she got my resume she wants me to see me
for an interview
so at this point i'm still mad i've i
feel like it's the same retail store but
it's in a different location
but i still feel like they're going to
tell me the same thing
and so i go there um the following day
and um immediately i noticed that she's
very nice
and she's uh
very opening up to me she talks to me
about how the job is and then she
and then she asked me the basic
interview questions um
and then
after she looks at me and she says do
you want to be a supervisor
um i was kind of shocked because at 19
years old
a supervisor who gets a job like that
i don't have much experience looked at
my resume
i don't know what
looks good on that resume to give me
that position but nonetheless i say yes
um what are the duties
so she goes on ahead and
tells me about everything what i have to
do and she's really happy i'm really
happy too
but everything happened so fast she i
gave her my id for a background check
all that stuff
and then she tells me to come here let's
go to the back and she'll introduce me
to everyone yeah that i'm supposed to
supervise yeah and so i look at everyone
and then i notice there's three muslim
women
i could not stop looking at them i guess
i just
i got so happy they probably thought i
was weird but i just could not stop
looking at them three of them when i you
know i even prayed for you know friends
for
just a muslim to be around for me to
talk to whenever i'm going through stuff
with my family
so um
yeah i look at all of them i meet them
and they're very nice um they're a lot
older than me but to me it really
doesn't matter yeah um
so
yeah and
and then i left
um i got in my car
and then i started crying
again
i started crying because i felt like
i was mad at
allah
for
not being
able to give me a job but then he gives
me a job plus
muslims around me
so
he gave me what i was praying for in one
day
yeah and you know in a place where
i could experience that you know are you
still in contact with them
um i'm in contact with one of them
they left for personal reasons but yes
um they've brought me a lot of comfort
and they helped me a lot with islam
that's amazing so now that's that's
that's amazing that's apparently and
when allah answered what things were
really smooth very fast
you'll see this is allah like things got
very smooth very fast um
so now coming to your
mom and dad yeah
um how are they like
you know we did say that you know your
mom is really really against
you know tell us tell us a bit about
what you what are you struggling with
so um
i really want to wear her job
but i feel like um
my mom
she doesn't like it i've shown her how i
would look if i'm
you know a hijabi but she said that
she told me like she looked me straight
in the eye and said why are you trying
to be around so bad
and i was like it's not it's not the
same thing islam is not you know a
culture islam is a religion it's not the
same thing
there are muslims who are black white
hispanic you know
so i was trying to explain her to her
that she's she said
that i'm that i'm beautiful why are you
trying to cover it up
how are you going to find a boyfriend a
husband with all that on
so um
yeah and
when i did tell my mom that i was muslim
she cried um
she
she was very merciful at first but then
um
i showed her a video of this hispanic
girl who was muslim and she was
explaining all the beliefs of a muslim
and then once she said that jesus is not
god that we don't believe that jesus is
god my mom just flipped
right mom
yeah she
she started arguing arguing with me she
was really mad she kept shaking her head
and arms crossed and everything
she was just really mad um
and so i just paused the video
i didn't even let her finish the video
and i went upstairs
because i
didn't want her to be even more
get even more riled up so i just went
upstairs and that was that
so
sorry
so um
when it came to my dad my dad actually
walked in on me and my mom argued
yeah
yeah and so um
and so he was like what are you guys
arguing about and then my mom told him
that i want to be muslim
yeah so
my dad i started explaining to my dad my
dad i felt like he was more lenient he
would be more lenient to me yeah being
muslim
but it wasn't the case
he said
he started brushing me off away he
started saying that
i don't want to hear it
you shouldn't you need to stop reading
books um throw that book away or i'll
throw it away for you
he was talking about the brawn while i
was talking to him about the quran yeah
and he said the devil is getting inside
of you you need to stop reading books
all of that and i just i really didn't
have anything to say
when he said that because i felt that he
would be my
savior i guess but no my parents were
totally against it they didn't like it
and
yeah i feel i feel like the day i became
muslim the day i took my shahada that my
parents became even more religious
instead of just going once a week to
church yeah they would go two
two three four times a week and they
would force me start forcing me to go to
church with me
really so since you became a muslim your
parents became more devoted to
christianity
yes
so i felt like i needed
you know
to be guided to christianity that i was
falling off or something
so you did say that your mom said like
if you don't leave islam i'll
like i'll kill myself or something like
that
yes so um
so after i told her i was muslim a few
weeks after after that during those
weeks she would just every time i came
home she would either be mad at me start
arguing arguing with me or she started
crying
so this day she was crying and she was
she looked very disheveled she looked
very sad
so i came up to her and i asked her what
was wrong
and
she said that she keeps having dreams of
me like
black water seeping into my room she
keeps having bad dreams of me drowning
stuff like that
she said are you still muslim she kept
asking me are you still must
and she was crying she was leaning over
the sink
well because she makes dinner um
but yeah and i started crying as well
and um
she said that um
yesterday the day before she told me all
that that
she tried to kill herself she tried to
take her life
because she felt like i was
um making her stressed i was making her
depressed
um
and
that was not my intention at all no no
of course not i told you that
yeah and so um i felt like she was
blaming me
sorry all right worry don't worry don't
take it take it down you know
subhanallah look you know it reminds me
of a story
and the sahaba's name was
and if i know if it's the correct
companion his mom
did very similar things
where he said look you know and i think
he was came from a very wealthy family
he said look we're gonna cut you know
everything his mom even at one point
from the mistake and said that i'm not
gonna eat
uh i'm like i'm gonna basically starve
myself
and you know he he said mom you know he
made a specific statement i can't
remember
uh but they basically actually said look
with all respect mom like whatever you
do i'm not gonna leave islam i'm just
saying that there was companions who
went through the same things um and if
i'm not mistaken his mom came to islam
from a mistake and i'll double check
that
but the thing is here look um
ibrahimov's dad i can remember a point
in my life when i was at home
um and with my dad as well like for
example you know
i and i went for the same thing our
parents are not evil yeah um they can be
like every parent can be but it's
genuinely their care they hear the story
about islam and stuff like that they
genuinely care so don't see them as you
know people who they have bad intentions
that you're their child you're the child
you know with the children and they want
the best for us like you would have kids
as well we want the best for them so the
thing is do not see them as coming from
a place where they hate you they don't
hate you they care for you and because
this is alien they don't know believe me
even the thing that you mentioned that
your mom said to you that if you put
this hijab or no one's going to marry
you is a sad reality
in today's time where you know women are
made to feel and this is an issue of
tawheed tawhid meaning the oneness of
allah where your trust is in yourself
and it's not just with you sadly in
today's time we have a lot of
you know sisters as well
who try to dress up in a certain way et
cetera because they believe
that to find the right man is in their
hands so you know taking my hijab or
showing my hijab or wearing really tight
clothing etc what they're doing in a
nutshell is saying
i
i'm not saying directly saying this but
it's like okay i don't have trust allah
will find me someone the one who's
created the heavens and the earth and
the stars and the moon and the galaxy he
can't find me a husband i need to take
the matters in my hand and the beauty
industry does this you know in the
society as a whole does this um you know
and i would personally advise you to
read a book it's called beauty sick and
i read this a lot actually mohammadi
jabs here yeah um
he's here he'll come here
you know she watched your video with
david wood and that's when the reason
she accepted islam yeah can you come say
salam just on the camera yeah because
this is and i i sent your video to him
he's here come the kids come out just
lean over that camera
[Laughter]
so nice
and she was watching church videos yeah
and your videos keep popping up and
she'll keep ignoring it keep ignoring it
and then until she watched it was two
hours she goes oh let me watch it yeah
and i was i thought yeah if you need
anything yeah definitely we're gonna
we're gonna get connected with you thank
you i couldn't think yeah you're in
america yeah yeah yeah yes i am
state it's called airlines south
carolina south carolina oh is that red
state yeah that's
[Laughter]
uh yeah yeah she's only there's only a
few of them yeah it's not it's not a big
muslim community there no no no no no
probably handsome that's why it's it's
really sad you know stuff she's going
through it it was mostly
the one whose mom friend is right
i think so yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just
telling her uh so yeah like you know
even it was a good it's a good um when i
was hearing it's a good uh yeah
comparison yeah yeah it's almost like
for life it's it's life it's nearly like
for life because that's what she said as
well you know um but look like i said
sister i genuinely believe wallahi yeah
not from
what i want to say sister is that read
this book yeah by the way the reason i
mentioned the book is because they
always laugh because i always read it is
that the only book but the point is if
you read it's called beauty sick yeah
i'll send you he's laughing now
um he's laughing now yeah so the thing
is but what that does is because what
your mom said is if you cover yourself
you're not going to find anybody so what
that means is that socially we've been
so um conditioned especially females
that you have to look a certain way and
be a certain way in order to get you
know married or attract opposite gender
you know um and that is a sad reality
and what when you come to islam you you
know cover yourself obviously you know
for the sake of surprise
but obviously because you want people to
you're a human being as a female you
have more to offer than your body part
and it's such a sad state of affairs
that women think that the only thing
that they have to offer is how you look
a new form of your latino right
yes and we know the latinos they are
very about their looks you know they
have very very plastic surgery you know
i heard of a woman who died because of
it you know sadly so the thing is here
i personally believe wallahi i genuinely
believe inshallah we ask allah to guide
your mom and dad that one day we will
speak to you
and look don't lose hope you're going to
have days i've had that yeah where i'm
hopeful my dad comes to me or says
something about god and i'm like wow
and i'm like there's a sign you know
he's and then there's a day he comes and
i'm just like wow like i don't think
he's ever gonna accept islam and you're
gonna have these moments you know and i
had this moment when once my dad was
really really harsh towards me i left
the house i went on a train and opened
the quran and he went to to a specific
verse where it was about ibrahimovic his
dad how his dad was towards him yeah um
what time is isha
eight okay all right okay 10 minutes
um so the thing is here and when i
opened it and i was like wow like you
know it talks about his dad and how his
dad was with him so the thing is here
look never lose hope yeah never lose
hope make your dua and i believe allah
subhanahu wa tala has chosen you and
wallahi do not be surprised you might be
one of the first people that may be in
south carolina a big community of
muslims are going to be built and you
are going to be the at the forefront of
that you know so don't ever lose hope
you're going to go through these
struggles you are going to appreciate
the struggles later on you're going to
see wow allah put me through this this
and this because of that yeah and the
more
your mom
becomes hostile you need to with your
act your manners the prophet peace be
upon him said i came for nothing but to
perfect with adam yeah having good adept
starts with allah yeah well how does
what does adam sorry but you know what
it means like madness yeah
yeah man it's like having good manners
starts with allah when you come and say
oh allah
your son you have a son of god or allah
you are free to try young god or the the
the pagan arabs in arabia used to say
that they used to ascribe female angels
as the daughters of god somehow on those
lines yeah this is having bad adept with
allah you're having bad manners with god
so what you've done is sister nara is
just fix those manners with allah by
saying
there is nothing worthy of worship
except you you fix that affairs and then
what you've said is and and muhammad
sallallahu sallam is your final
messenger and you've had management with
allah then you corrected your manners
with the prophet sallam and now you're
going to correct your manners with
yourself which you have and as a
community are large like your mom and
the following so do not ever lose hope
and
be gentle with them yeah allah tells us
after worshiping him to be obedient to
your parents okay some people come and
say oh islam you know like islam is the
devil's religion before we start
reciting the quran we say i will be
seek refuge in god from the cursed satan
i mean what kind of religion is is that
that curses states in 24 7. you know um
so the thing is sister the reason why i
wanted to do this video is because i was
really touched by a video where you i
saw you crying multiple times and i can
you know resonate with that because i've
had moments look i'm a man after moments
where i cried as well yeah where i'm in
despair and you know things are going i
had i was kicked out my house you know i
was staying in one of my friend's house
for about a month i stayed in this house
etc you know there was issues in the
house and my mom was having issues with
my dad you know what's your problem with
him what's he doing to you etc oh he's a
traitor the thing is these things happen
and it really has a tone on you you know
where you're just like okay you know you
feel left out but in these moments
sometimes you do feel i don't know if
you felt that where the harder it gets
the
i can't explain it the sweeter it feels
in a way where you're like okay i'm i'm
going through this for the sake of god
if it doesn't feel good as well
yeah exactly so like even yours like
your situation you're in now is if i'm
not mistaken when you drive home like
you have to take two hours so your
family
doesn't find out so
yeah i had to take uh two hours off work
um just so i don't have to ask my mom
for
for permission to go out because i know
she'll probably because on friday i do
want to go to the bus to take my
shahada again and hopefully meet some
sisters
and so i want to ask for permission for
that obviously disguising it as you know
going out to a friend's house and if i'm
not mistaken you have to take your hijab
off when you go home so what are you
wearing now
yes i
put it on in my car in the driveway and
then i go to work with it and then i
come back um
and take it off in the driveway as well
it's like the time of the sahaba you
know when they had to migrate from mecca
under persecution you are in a form of
obedience as you are going through the
sister you are in continuous obedience
continuous like
we know the struggles et cetera
and while you teach us such a big lesson
even for born muslims you know it's it's
sad that we live here today that there
are sisters and brothers as well
brothers have their own struggles with
et cetera but because your system
referring to that they said the in
muslim families who go in the car and
they take the hijab off and go out you
know and
well there is this is a reality you know
sadly you know about you know and and
everyone has their struggles you know
everyone you know has the struggles but
the thing is you're here as a revert who
is trying to wear the hijab so much so
that your family doesn't know you know
i've had that you know like praying in
secret etc you know like my dad just two
three years ago caught me praying and
and i can't describe that feeling i
cannot describe that feeling where after
five six years of praying and then the
first time your dad catches you
i cannot describe that feeling of
fear anxiety
and
it's undescribable i can't describe it
but it's and then at that moment when
you look for mercy you know i'm not
saying my dad beat me up but when you're
looking for that mercy where you're
thinking okay maybe he just saw me
praying and something changed from his
heart and then he turns around and says
don't ever do that in my house again
and you're just like wow like and it's
just another somebody punches you in the
nose and then you're thinking he's gonna
have mercy and then he punches you in
the jaw
uh so the thing is that once again look
my dad like there's things that he's
experienced and i make dwarf until this
day we have discussion etc it's much
better it's much better than before but
the point is this
you know don't give up uh because
believe me and i'll wrap up on this as
well um you know when i got married to
my wife
um i can remember you know he was saying
that i'm
i'm not gonna come to your wedding yeah
and um i went through a lot of struggles
in my marriage search and at the last
moments allah rolled the red carpet out
for me things were really smooth
handling there and i can remember and i
was thinking i was sad but he ended up
coming to the mosque inside the mosque
to do my manika he was there with my
cousins so what i'm just saying sister
for my for my dad to be in a mosque to
me is massive
for my dad to walk in a mosque it's
tremendous and the one who's created the
heavens and the earth sister can guide
you with mom and dad it's not hard i'll
wrap up on that that's it that's what i
wanted to say may allah bless you
inshallah keep you firm we're going to
get some people in contact with you and
while you are an inspiration for us um
you are a role model for us i'll be
honest with you because the fact that
you're living in the state where there's
hillbillies walking with guns and you're
you're rolling this hijab i mean you're
a soldier we have to salute you here you
know we have to from london to
south carolina carolina wherever it is
um
it's it's amazing it really really is
amazing and i just wanted to say this to
you yeah and i i said to you look even
if it's off camera on camera even if you
come and see it in brazil don't put this
up i wanted to say that message to you
that no as your brothers we're here for
you anything that you need we're going
to get some sisters in contact with you
as well inshallah don't ever feel alone
anything that happens you got my
instagram you message me whatever it is
inshallah we are here for you um may
allah subhanahu wa bless you and keep
you firm and don't forget and mark my
words they will come inshaallah your mom
will accept islam yeah okay um because i
see you know she's going through
difficulties in life etc
be soft be patient make dua the word the
process that i've said is one of the
most powerful
things for a believer yeah you fix the
affairs of allah do the do the things
that uh has told you fasting given zakah
praying etc abstaining from major sins
your
your dua is like a rocket and in today's
time it's not a atomic bomb you know
that doesn't obviously kill innocent
people but alhamdulillah you know that's
a wonderful thing inshallah maybe it's a
wrong example to use but the point is
this it
you will see it you will see it trust me
inshallah and make lots of dua
allah subhana wa salah
um any last words anything you want to
say
no i just want to thank you ali dawa and
all of you guys as well um
thank you it means a lot that you really
watched
my video and
i just want to say thank you to everyone
else who did go and watch my video
i appreciate everyone um you know it
does feel alone but i have a whole world
of muslims
[Music]
so if there's any sisters who would like
to message the
sister nora and keep support to and keep
in contact um it will be a pleasure
inshallah until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi